نسمع دويه الاشتباكات او اصوات الاشتباكات
من خلفك الان ما
التفاصيل نعم بالفعل محمود
الاشتباكات المسلحه اي يعني يمكن ان توصف
بالعنيف تحديدا في حي الجابريات المطل على
المخيم ولكن دعنا نبدا من هذه الصوره عبر
عدسه الكاميرا لهذه السحابه من الدخان في
حي الجابريات المطل على
المخيم وفق شهود عيان فان مقاومين
فلسطينيين تمكنوا من تفجير عبوه ناسفه
باليه عسكريه في هذه الاثناء نستمع معك
محمود لصوت القران الكريم والتكبيرات تصدح
من ماذن المساجد في مدينه ومخيم جنين دعما
للمقاومين الفلسطينيين ايضا في بيان عاجل
اعلنت كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس
وكتائب الاقصى التابعه لحركه فتح وكتائب
عز الدين القسام ل التابعه لحركه حماس في
بيان عاجل بان المجموعات تقوم ب وتخوض
اشتباكات عنيفه مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتقوم بتفجير عبوات ناسفه
بالجيش كنا قبل حوالي الساعه محمود قد
اعلمنا بانه تم اطلاق دوي صافرات الانذار
هذه الصافرات التي عاده ما يشغلها
المقاومون
والاهالي تحذيرا من دخول قوات الاحتلال
واقتحام المدينه والمخيم قبل خمس دقائق
عادت ودوت صافرات الانذار للاعلان بان
قوات جديده دخلت من حاجز الجلمه بجنوبي
جنين اتجاه المدينه ولكن بعض الصور
والفيديوهات
من
بعض المقاومين تم نشرها عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تظهر انفجار كبير ناتج عن هذه
سحابه الدخان التي كنا قد رايناها قبل
قليل والانفجار كان بالقرب من اليه عسكريه
على الاقل استطعنا ان نسمع صوت دوي
انفجارين في السماء وفي في محيط المخيم
الذي يظهر عبر عدسه الكاميرا ولكن لا
نستطيع التاكيد ولكن شهود عيان يؤكدون انه
في حي الجابريات في اعلى مدي اعلى منطقه
مطله على المخيم هناك اشتباكات مسلحه
عنيفه جدا في هذه اللحظات يعني هدوء حذر
جدا لا نعرف ان كان هناك
اي حدث شيء لان اي وفق ايضا بيانات
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تقوم باطلاق النار بشكل وصف
بالستي بعد كمائن استهدفت عدد من الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه واضح ان امام عمليه
عسكريه واسعه هذه الليله ولكن خلال الايام
الماضيه كنا نرى الاقتحامات قد خفت الان
نستمع للاشتباكات مجددا يعني خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه لم يكن هناك اقتحامات وكن
يبدو اننا امام ليله جديده فيها اقتحام
للمدينه ولل المخيم وبانتظار ما ستقول
اليه الساعات القادمه